qui s'est passé Gilles alors ce qui
choque énormément et perturbent même les
enquêteurs c'est que ce jeune agresseur
n'a pas d'antécédent judiciaire il est
inconnu des services de police et qui a
pas eu d'altercation avant il s'est
précipité sur l'enseignante une
enseignante qui je crois était proche de
la retraite et on dit c'est une
enseignante expérimentée très calme et
c'est précipité sur elle avec un couteau
il l'a frappé au cou alors c'était pas
effectivement lui qui était en cours
avec cette enseignante l'enseignante a
crié à ce moment-là j'ai rien fait et
puis elle est tombée alors ce qui se dit
peut-être que vous allez nous le
confirmer c'est que il y aurait eu un
conflit entre deux élèves et que
peut-être cet enseignante aurait essayé
à sa manière pacifiquement de régler le
conflit et qu'elle aurait pris parti
est-ce que vous avez entendu parler de
ça c'est les dernières pistes qui sont
relevées par les enquêteurs alors au
moment de l'acte nous étions pas dans la
classe seulement dans le même étage mais
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il y a une
élève qui était dans cette trou dans
cette salle là et du coup l'élève il
rentre dans la salle il avait pas cours
avec la prof il